c'est quelque chose renault c'est un
fleuron de notre histoire industrielle
de notre histoire économique de notre
histoire sociale aussi à bien des égards
c est un groupe mondial par l'alliance
qu'il a su construire et défendre avec
nissan et avec mitsubishi
c'est un groupe enraciné dans notre pays
vous avez cité flins dans les yvelines
bien entendu je pourrais moi même site
et sandouville dans cette maritime dont
je me réjouis d'ailleurs que et puisse à
nouveau fonctionner le 22 mai prochain
et c'est un groupe dont l'état est
actionnaire
nous sommes donc attentifs extrêmement
attentifs vous l'imaginez bien les deux
choses qui sont mal ils sont à constater
avec la force de l'évidence
d'abord le secteur automobile pas
seulement en france
partout dans le monde connaît un coup de
frein si vous me permettez cette
expression massif et brutale vous avez
cité les chiffres des diminutions de
ventes pour le mois d'avril de l'ordre
de 75 à 80 % du jamais vu et ce chiffre
tout laisse à penser qu'il ne devrait
pas être excellent non plus au mois de
mai et c'est vrai pour renault comme ça
l'est d'ailleurs pour tous les autres
constructeurs à des degrés parfois un
peu divers m'enfin néanmoins dans des
ordres de grandeur qui sont assez
similaires donc premiers éléments le
secteur automobile dans sa globalité
connaît une transformation
massive ait jamais vue dont brutalité
une intensité jamais deuxième élément
que personne ne conteste et qui était
d'ailleurs déjà dans l'atmosphère si
j'ose dire avant la crise que nous
connaissons la nécessité pour renault
comme pour d'ailleurs toutes les acteurs
industriels singulièrement les acteurs
automobiles de poursuivre d'accélérer
d'approfondir ces opérations de
transformation et d'adaptation parce que
le marché compétitif parce que la
compétition d'ailleurs sur le secteur
automobile est féroce parce que les
transformations de produits sont doivent
être rapides avec l'électrification avec
la diminution des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre avec la nécessité donc
d'adapter cette culture automobile aux
exigences des temps nouveaux si vous
permettez ces grands mots mais enfin
c'est quand même bien ça dont il s'agit
la stratégie la nécessité que renault
dans laquelle renault se trouve c'est
d'abord d'abord de renforcer l'alliance
vous savez que pour renault c'est un
objet un enjeu vital
c'est ensuite d'adapter ses modèles son
organisation aux circonstances que nous
connaissons
c'est de renforcer sa compétitivité et
c'est un effort qui doit toujours être
assumés consentis car on ne vit pas
durablement pour le marché automobile si
on n'est pas compétitive et et on
disparaît rapidement sécurisé sa
capacité d'investissement
les coûts fixes de renault sont
considérables comme toute grande
entreprise industrielle d'ailleurs sans
recettes parce que sans vente
la sécurisation de ses capacités de sa
trésorerie et de ses capacités
d'investissement bien l'enjeu majeur est
l'état vous l'avez dit est au rendez
vous pour la compagnie je pense que le
constructeur suis pas directeur de la
stratégie de cette entreprise j'ai par
son président mais je pense que le
constructeur doit formuler un plan qui
est un plan non pas défensif mais
offensif il est toujours mieux dans ces
circonstances de franchir plus vite
encore les étapes qu'on prévoyait de
franchir plutôt que d'essayer de
défendre le plus longtemps possible une
position qui en vérité serait un table
nous serons extrêmement attachés
intransigeant même je dirais à la
préservation du site france décident
france renault est une entreprise
mondiale c'est vrai mais enfin ça marque
française est évidente et donc nous
serons extrêmement exigeant sur ce point
nous serons extrêmement exigeants sur le
fait que la france demeure le centre
mondial pour renault de l'ingénierie de
la recherche de l'innovation du
développement
c'est quelque chose dont vous savez
d'ailleurs dans le département des
yvelines
c'est combien ces précieux pour préparer
l'avenir et pour garder une capacité à
préparer l'avenir nous serons
extrêmement attaché et je crois que le
président de l'entreprise est
extrêmement attaché lui aussi à la
qualité du dialogue et de
l'accompagnement social
personne ici ne met en doute je crois
les capacités et l'attachement du
président de renault au dialogue et à
l'accompagnement social dans les
décisions et dans la stratégie qui doit
être prise c'est avec cette ce prisme
que nous allons étudier les propositions
du constructeur
vous avez évoqué des informations
relatives à un plan qui n'a pas encore
été présenté il est donc difficile
vous ne comprendrait parfaitement je
pense même la sénatrice pour moi de
répondre dans le détail un plan qui
n'est pas encore présente et qui n'est
donc probablement pas encore arrêté mais
je veux dire et rappeler et répondre à
votre question en disant notre
attachement au site de flins qui en
effet représente quelque chose dans le
fonctionnement de l'entreprise et qui
doit dans toute la mesure du possible
être préservé parce qu'il est je les dis
important
ce que nous sommes attachés aussi de
france et parce que il y a une forme de
responsabilité de l'entreprise a avancé
à se transformer à expliquer le besoin
de transformation mais aussi à tenir
compte des réalités du pays qui
l'accueille et qui d'une certaine façon
la fait vivre